this is serious folks hey everyone i'm
abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by better
help and we'll be talking all things
insulin now it seems to me like every
so-called expert out there on instagram
is claiming that insulin is the big bad
fat storage hormone
out to make you gain weight at any cost
but is insulin really to blame well
first let me tell you about my sponsor
better help so as you guys know i
struggled with anxiety my whole life and
getting my mental health under control
has been one of the most important
things i've been able to do
for my overall well-being and quality of
life but in 2022 i'm really committing
to my mental health and working with a
registered therapist has been so
imperative to helping to support my
goals so i recently discovered better
help which is the world's largest online
therapist network with over 20 000
licensed professional therapists
it's not a crisis line or a self-help
line it's professional therapy done
securely anywhere anytime online now the
way it works is that you just log into
your account anytime to send a message
to your therapist and you can get a
timely response without needing to wait
weeks between appointments i know how
important this is because we obviously
can't always plan when we're gonna have
a panic attack or have an anxious
episode so that it coincides with our
scheduled appointment
it's also a lot more affordable than
traditional in-person therapy and
there's also financial aid available for
those in need so if you're struggling
with your mental health check out
betterhelp.com
abby's kitchen to get 10 off of your
first month of therapy again that's
betterhelp h-e-l-p
and you can join over 1 million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional okay let's get back to
insulin so you can pause the screen or
look at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating i am
going to be getting into some nutrition
technicalities so as always feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey and if you're not
already subscribed hit that sub button
follow me over on tik tok and instagram
at abby's kitchen and i hope you enjoy
the video all right before i dive into
the crux of this let's first understand
how food affects blood sugar levels and
where insulin fits into this pretty
little picture when you eat any kind of
carb your body breaks this food down
into glucose a sugar the glucose gets
absorbed into your bloodstream where it
becomes known as blood sugar and your
blood ships the sugar to your cells to
be used for energy or to be stored for
later on now insulin is the hormone that
allows the glucose to get into the cells
and when it's inside
naturally your blood sugar levels drop
so think of insulin as the key that
unlocks the door to get glucose to do
its job without insulin your body
wouldn't be able to use or store glucose
and you'd be walking around with very
high blood sugar all day long and that's
bad news bears because if untreated high
blood sugar can cause organ damage over
time but let's get back to our frenemy
insulin so insulin is made in the
pancreas and is secreted in bursts about
every five minutes
if you haven't eaten the levels are
relatively low so this is called your
baseline level and when you eat your
insulin levels rise to deal with the
sugars now in your bloodstream and in a
healthy individual insulin comes right
back down to their normal steady state
once it's dealt with the sugar note that
our discussions today are going to be
for the general population aka folks who
have healthy working pancreases things
would be slightly different of course if
you had diabetes all right back to class
kids
recess is over so insulin also buddies
up with the hormone glucagon which tells
the liver to release glucose when the
blood sugar levels get too low it can
either access glycogen which is the
stored version of glucose in the liver
or the muscles or the liver can convert
any extra protein to glucose through a
process called
gluconeogenesis so this dream team works
together to keep your blood sugar levels
tightly controlled and regulated because
again high blood sugar levels are
dangerous as
so we can see this amazing control in
action in a 2020 study that's been
affectionately known as the
all-you-can-eat pizza study i like the
sound of that
pizza time they basically offered a
group of healthy men pizza and asked
them to eat till they were comfortably
full and then again until they literally
couldn't take another bite without
bursting they really could have just
studied youtube milk bangers and saved a
[ __ ] ton of research dollars
but anyway the first conclusion they
found was that these healthy men could
eat twice as much as what made them feel
comfortably full so not exactly
intuitive eating experts but i'm way
more interested in what happened to
their blood sugar and their insulin
levels after all of those carbs
basically your girl insulin understood
the assignment the pancreas pumped that
out in a linear fashion the whole time
they were eating pizza the more pizza
they ate the more insulin their bodies
produced and because insulin is just
such a badass the blood sugar levels
rose up to a certain point and then
basically leveled off in fact their
blood sugar levels were the same whether
they ate 187 grams or
367 grams of carbs conclusion well in
healthy folks without diabetes our blood
sugar levels are tightly regulated
regardless of how much or what we eat so
i hear you abby what's the point of
eating healthy foods if insulin is just
always gonna correct for our dietary
shortcomings well this is where
intuition comes into play that is
focusing on how foods make you feel so
even though the participants blood sugar
levels remained normal albeit at the
higher end of normal they experienced
feelings of lethargy and poor energy
levels so physically they were fine but
maybe they weren't feeling their best so
now we know that in healthy individuals
eating carbs are not going to cause
uncontrolled blood sugar spikes but what
about insulin's role in storing fat so
insulin helps glucose get stored as
glycogen but it also helps to store
anything extra in your fat cells as a
long-term back-up plan for energy and
this is likely where it gets its
reputation as a big bad fat storage
hormone because as long as there's ample
glucose hanging around and therefore
insulin is out and about doing its job
there's no real need to break down fat
it's also true that fat breakdown is
greater two to four hours after you eat
which is when insulin would naturally be
at its lowest if insulin levels never go
down then theoretically that will also
never be broken down and when i spoke to
my colleague eric williamson he reminded
me that
these mechanisms are not like on or off
switches but rather they're more like
dials and getting those dials to even
work depend on a few things one to a
small extent is metabolic flexibility
folks who are more metabolically
flexible are better able to switch from
using glucose to fat for fuel i think
this deserves like a whole other video
so if you're interested in that please
let me know in the comments below
because it's a big topic but in short we
know that one's flexibility is related
to their insulin sensitivity body fat
percentage and aerobic fitness level we
also know that it's the leanest
anaerobic fitness that increases your
insulin sensitivity and thus better
equips the body for fat breakdown not
the other way around but even that
potential leg up in the game doesn't
guarantee weight loss without a solid
caloric deficit in other words
regardless of your fasting insulin
levels you're still going to add to your
fat reserves if you eat more calories
than you need period so when an
influencer tells you that you can just
cut out carbs and eat as many calories
as you want because it's the carbs that
spike your insulin and insulin stores
fat it's
just missing the forest from the trees
and that forest my friends
is just excess calories a number of
studies have found that it doesn't
matter how macros are split weight loss
is primarily influenced by the amount of
energy the person consumes for example
one small metabolic lab study divided
participants into a low carb and a high
carb diet and told them to eat as much
as they wanted while the high carb group
had substantially higher insulin levels
they ended up actually eating about 700
calories less and actually lost weight
in comparison to the low carb group
likewise long-term research suggests
that it doesn't matter if you're on low
carb or high carb weight loss is
virtually identical when calories are
the same we can also look at the other
side of the coin to study insulin and
weight loss on a low carb diet so one
2015 experimental study found that while
a low-carb diet did lower insulin levels
it didn't result in more weight loss in
fact in this case specifically the folks
on the low-fat diet lost more than the
ones on the low carb and to bring it all
together a large systematic review found
little to no difference between diets
too so i say that puts the diet wars
piece to bed
for the impact of insulin as a fat
storage hormone it really doesn't appear
to have any measurable impact on weight
gain or weight loss we know this because
when calories are the same folks with
and without diabetes or insulin
resistance will lose the same amount of
weight so to summarize while a higher
carb diet does transiently increase
insulin levels it doesn't affect weight
in the short or the long term the bottom
line remains that calories are king so
how does all this play into the claims
that are made by folks who intermittent
fast well a lot of iaf groupies insist
that intermittent fasting has a magical
weight loss power because it reduces the
number of insulin episodes in the day
and it keeps insulin levels low as often
as possible thus increasing metabolic
flexibility and in a vacuum that might
be true however as i've already
discussed in my video on intermittent
fasting here the primary mechanism for
why intermittent fasting works
is not because of insulin or metabolic
flexibility it's because we're just kind
of bad at making up for calories mist
when we skip a meal once again folks it
boils down to calories insulin is just
the convenient scapegoat here so does
that mean that there are no benefits to
fasting no i'm definitely not saying
that i mean we know that in addition to
potentially promoting weight loss
largely via caloric deficit from skipped
meals like i said fasting may positively
affect insulin sensitivity so in super
duper short a higher insulin sensitivity
means that your cells are able to use
glucose more effectively to help bring
down those blood sugar levels while a
low insulin sensitivity aka insulin
resistance is known as a precursor to
diabetes so research suggests that those
practicing early time restricted eating
so eating earlier on in the day and
stopping earlier on in the day tend to
have better insulin sensitivity than
those who are eating later on at night
i've spoken about this before briefly
but this does have a lot to do with our
natural circadian alignment which is our
sleep wake cycles as it seems that
aligning our food intake with daylight
hours can benefit our metabolism and our
glucose response strangely most people
who swear they're doing intermittent
fasting tend to have the opposite eating
schedule so they skip breakfast and
maybe skip lunch and they eat from
afternoon until night so they might
actually be missing out on one of the
unique perks and instead just kind of
skipping a meal but how can we use all
of this information in real life if
weight loss is the goal so my suggestion
is to take the focus off of specific
hormones like insulin and to choose
foods that keep us feeling fuller for
longer while making a caloric deficit
easier to maintain and this is where my
hunger crushing combo comes in by
combining high fiber carbs protein and
healthy fats together it helps to
promote long-term fullness and
ultimately the more satiated and
satisfied you are the less likely you
are to binge or to snack and eat in
caloric surplus
if we break this down further there are
unique benefits to all three of these
components high fiber carb-based foods
generally have a lower glycemic response
even on their own when compared to
refined carbohydrates but their
absorption is slowed down even more by
adding in a source of protein and or
fats this combo leads to a lower more
sustained rise in both blood sugar and
insulin which may help to keep you
fuller for a longer period of time and
keep those energy levels even keeled
even if you've got like a hankering for
a low fiber carb like white rice you can
still lower the glycemic response
significantly by simply adding in some
chicken avocado and some veg my hunger
crushing combo also works because the
addition of fiber protein and fats helps
to delay gastric emptying which keeps
you feeling fuller longer between meals
and therefore it reduces the need to
mindlessly snack now a lot of you guys
have shared with me posts that you've
seen on instagram about having to have
your first bite of a meal be a non-carb
food like veggies to help coat the
stomach before the carbs hit to help
produce the glycemic response
[Music]
and while i know it sounds like total
total bs there is actually some merit to
this so we have some small studies and
research mainly in the diabetes
population showing some benefits to
consuming the veggies and protein before
the carbs in your meal but here's the
thing you don't need to like separate
all your food out unnaturally if you're
eating a mixed meal let's say like pasta
with a veggie and meat bolognese sauce
you're gonna get those insulin
stabilizing benefits even if your first
bite doesn't
contain like a honking piece of broccoli
but when i spoke to a glucose goddess
about this on instagram she suggested
just doing it when it makes sense in
that meal so if you're having a salad
with your pasta start with a bit of
salad if you can but you don't need to
be obsessive about this my colleagues
like eric agreed that being more
intentional may be more helpful for
folks with existing insulin resistance
or diabetes but it isn't as important a
tool as more basic strategies like
choosing more whole foods over refined
so
dressing up our naked carbs with hunger
crushing compounds is something that i
think we can aim to do more often but
freaking out if you accidentally eat a
bite of pasta before your broccoli is
likely to do
more harm than good so to quickly just
wrap up here yes insulin has a role in
fat storage but controlling it is not
the magic bullet to weight loss that so
many wellness influencers insist it to
be so i say focus on eating balanced
meals using whole foods regularly
throughout the day and all those my new
little details will just
work themselves right out and on that
note that is all that i have for you
guys today thanks again to better health
for sponsoring if you like this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up leave me a
comment below if there are any other
major nutrition questions that you guys
want me to answer subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]